it's also the element of how many of
these kids who are going through this
process
are they're just gay they're just gay
kids I mean
whenever I you know because the show has
got quite big now I
the people who come up to me
I get quite a lot of gay men and gay
women wanting to talk to me about this
and I remember talking to this gay lady
makes me sound like I'm from the 1950s
when I say that but a few weeks ago and
we were talking about this and she
approached me and we were having a nice
conversation and she just looked at me
and she went
thank God that I'm in my late 20s
because if this had been around
when I was 12
I would have transitioned and I would
have screamed the house down until
you know there was medical intervention
because that's how upset it was at the
fact that I was gay or I am gay I think
this is the part of the story which
people particularly in
you know
liberal
metropolitan cities find the hardest to
accept
and certainly that's like the reaction
that I've had
to the work like it just can't be true
you know and clinicians themselves
they would get young people coming in
and using these vile homophobic slurs
that you know that we had at school in
the I think we're probably a similar age
you know the 80s and 90s and
and hearing that I kind of I thought we
were done with that I thought it just
wasn't a thing anymore to
for people to think it's not okay to be
gay but it but it is and it's not me
saying that like every condition I spoke
to said that so many of those young
people were same-sex attracted even
those that spoke really favorably about
the work edges and particularly the
girls and actually when
those clinicians who were gay themselves
raise those concerns they say they were
accused of being too close to the work
that they were seeing something that
wasn't there and what they've turned
around and says look they say look at
the data like it's really rubbish like
we don't have much of it but what we do
have absolutely bears that out
so jizz's data for every single young
person that was referred to them in 2012
of the ones they have data for which is
the sort of the older ones they didn't
ask the very young kids
uh what is it I think 90 percent
of the girls identified as either the
same sex attracted as well or bisexual
and eighty percent of the boys and then
a slightly more recent stats those come
down to about 70 and 60 respectively but
they're still incredibly High
so they're saying we weren't seeing
something that wasn't there and I've
spoken to young people themselves
there's a there's a case in the book
Harriet who said I was a lesbian and it
was so obvious I went into my kids
assessment and I talked about the first
relationship that I'd had with a girl
and I felt really ashamed about it
because she wouldn't talk to me in
public and I've never been attracted to
a boy and all that was ignored
so it's not
it
the data the personal experiences the
experiences the clinicians it it's there
and I have to stress that of the people
I spoke to for the book not all of whom
are named or quoted but collectively
they've worked with thousands of young
people directly sitting in a room like
we are now face to face it's not
it's just I don't think it's credible to
pretend that the overwhelming
number of people who might be
uh affected by by this um
are gay bisexual or lesbian I mean and
that has always been the case so every
study we have in this field is quite
rubbish but all of them
highlighted that and when Domenico De
Chelly opened jids back in 89 he always
made that point
that of this of any group of kids some
would grow up to be trans
but there would be the minority the
majority wouldn't and the majority of
them would be gay
and somehow this gets lost over the
years even though it was in the clinical
presentations and even though their own
data showed them that
foreign